hello everyone and welcome to another
most interesting game from the Croatian
Grantchester being played in Zagreb it's
around 3 Sharma media versus Yanni
policy and it's well it's really a crazy
game but we're used to that when when
nepo is playing and I'm sorry I don't
have any photos I only get the photos on
the next day so we're gonna enjoy them
tomorrow on a separate video so without
further ado let's just check out the
game it's a really exciting one so let's
go mama Gareth has the white pieces and
he opens with d4 we have Knight to f6 c4
g6 and Knight to f3 now with Bishop to
g7 and just III with castles by Neto and
now Bishop to e2 with d6 preparing a 5
and now Knight to c3 just developing
pieces night bt7
the main idea in this line and Mama drf
castles here with E 5 by Neto and here
b3 preparing to fiend get the dark
square bishop with rook to e8 and here
there are a lot of games have reached
this position Bishop to b2 is the main
move in this position but here
Mamiya replace h3 it's not a new move
but it's been played only once before
and the reply to h3 was c6 but here
never goes efore as mom you did not
reply to this challenge in the center
nipple plays a new move so already as of
move 9 a completely new position and a
completely new game so let's see how
mommy our affairs in this newly found
position as he's the one that played the
very rare line h3 so tonight backed d2
pressuring the e4 pawn and now comes h5
with before mama Diaw who grabs more
space on the Queen side and nice the f8
this Knight is now going to h7 and nepos
plan is to move this night get this
Queen somehow to g5 as all of whites
pawns are now on dark squares so you
will not be able to oppose the Queen
with a dark square bishop and also you
cannot use the f3 square square for your
knight and then some nice tactics with
Bishop captures on h3 will be possible
with rook to e1 by Mahmoud Arif and now
Bishop to f5 a nice developing move
Bishop to b2 and now Queen to d7 and
there aren't any threats of Bishop
captures here Bishop f1 is a very strong
defensive piece so not a problem there
and here mama Dee are of could continue
playing on the Queen side with something
like a four but here he chooses Knight
to d5 he wants to open up the C file and
make the c7 on a weak bond never says no
problem we have Knight captures C
captures and now just Queen to e7
continuing with his plan the Queen will
now successfully get to g5 and here look
the c1 putting pressure on the c7 pawn
the c7 point is now a weak backwards
pawn and of course mama dro wants to
capitalize on that night the h7 now also
the knight will be able to join the game
either via Knight to g5 or maybe Knight
to f6 and then who knows where the night
might go from there we have Queen to c2
now preparing to capture and c7 and here
neighbor says you just go ahead I'm just
gonna play Queen to g5 and now it's
already dangerous the Queen and Bishop
in front of mom you're asking the I mean
the basic threat Bishop captures on h3
is on the board and here you wanna play
King to h1 it seems like such a such a
natural move just get the King out of
the way you don't want Bishop captures
on h3 and then if Queen h4 you simply
repeat King Jiwon and continue playing
the game but here to everyone's
amazement Mahmud Arab did not react to
this threat he he instead captured on c7
so okay you grab a pawn you're gonna
grab another pawn but do you really want
wanna be under attack on the Kings side
when when nipple has the black black
pieces for the price of one pawn well
mama drf does and he loves the Bishop
captures and h3 so now Queen the g2 will
be checkmate if Mahmud Europe does not
prevent it of course he prevents it with
Bishop to f1 you know just everything is
cool and now Bishop the f8 now a nipple
wants to bring this bishop also into the
attack and he has some ideas how he can
wiggle it in via via the king side and
maybe if if the this pawn moves he can
also maybe use it as an
attacking peace which you'll see later
with Queen captures mv7 grabbing yet
another pawn but not only grabbing a
pawn also creating an escape route for
the Queen as well the King side is about
to get attacked so we want to play King
Queen to a6 and basically the idea is
that if this Bishop is sacrificed here
then you will be able to push our pawn
and then attack the bishop so the Queen
will be able to retreat to f1 it's not
the greatest square for the Queen but
you've grabbed some points now you want
to go back and defend with Knight to f6
by Napo and now Queen to a6 preparing to
go to f1 if this ever happens but nipple
doesn't like this so he could play h4
and then sacrifice here like we said and
then push h3 but neppo doesn't want to
allow the Queen to retreat so first he
pushes the Queen back Queen to c8 sorry
Bishop to ca now the bishop cannot
retreat to f1 as the Bishop occupies
that square so first Queen to a4 but now
nepo attacks it again will rush up to d7
and now Queen to d1 so mama D off brings
the Queen back to the starting Square
from there the Queen will be able to
help out with the defense and now push
up the g4 so now if you just move the
Queen to to some square let's say for
back which doesn't really make sense
then this Bishop has come from Age 3 to
g4 without losing any time because every
move was made with an attack on the
Queen so here you could play some of the
commercial t2 but then you get Bishop to
h3 and after Bishop to f1 again
defending mate not h4 is coming and now
again this becomes a threat and the
Queen is not ready to take the bishops
place on f1 so after Bishop g4 my Medea
of played f3 attacking the bishop and
here we have e captures on f3 Knight
captures with an attack on the Queen and
Queen to h6 now so what did mama D are
get for the price of this one pawn well
he's under attack his structure in front
of the King is all messed up he does
have a strong central central mass here
but it's hard to say if you will be able
to use it if you get checkmate it
so here you want to play something like
Queen to d2 keep an eye on the e3 pawn
and
well keep the Queen closed to help out
with the defense but hereafter Queen to
b3 it becomes a bit more difficult here
nipple 8h for but there's an even
greater forcing line after a bunch of
characters on f3g captures Queen g5
check and after you block Bishop to g2
now you play Bishop to h6 and now you
get this well triple threat against the
e3 pawn after the pawn moves now you
play g3 or otherwise white would just
lose upon and now this Bishop finally
finds its way into the attack via Bishop
to f4 and then it's gonna be really ugly
for the White King but neppo plays a
different line after Queen b3 he goes h4
first doesn't really care about any
forcing lines he just wants to play h3
and here mama Dee are off without any
ideas his position is just bad like
Geary against cross and in round one
he's getting slaughtered on the H file
and here he plays Knight to e5 he tries
to give up a piece for some initiative
and if if if pawn captures then you get
this very nice central structure here
but still after 94 it's gonna be very
hard to to play this with white even
with such a nice pawn center but Knepper
says I don't care like the honey badger
and he just pushes h3 he just continues
his attack he says I'm not interested in
your night here if you want you can cap
from my Bishop on g4 Mammadov goes for
it as neppo did not accept the peace
sacrifice with Knight captures Knight
captures and now G captures on h3
pushing the knight back but now Knight
captures on e3 and here what do you do
your king side is completely busted if
you count the points
Mauro is still up upon but who would you
rather play in this position I I don't
think we even need to ask this question
this Bishop is doing nothing for the
entire game as it's been blocked by its
own door opens on dark squares for the
entire game so not doing all that much
and it's very hard to activate the rooks
here rook the citrus plate okay if the
knight moves then the bishop and queen
are controlling the entire third rank so
that is good for
white but with nice to f5 by neppo he
offers afraid of rooks which ma media of
the clients he doesn't want to allow the
other hook to get activated so he plays
rook to d1 but now we have Queen to h5
just threatening not threatening but
pressuring the rook here if the Queen
moves and also what do you play here
would white here mom your plate
rook to f3 and here Napo just played
Bishop to h6 and it was in this position
that Sharma media resigned the game as
there is nothing to do here it seems
like there is something to do here but
there isn't whatever you play you just
you just lose the game terribly for
example if you try Bishop g2 I mean you
have to make a move and there aren't all
that many great moves if you play Bishop
to g2 then you just allow a nice a nice
infiltration by the rook after rook to
e2 and now whatever you do let's say
Bishop c1 you do something Bishop
captures rook captures and now Queen g5
is the threat of checkmate and also you
will lose the broken c1 so not the
greatest way to go but again there there
are no good ways to go here if you try
rogue d3 to bring another look on the
third-ranked then you get infiltrated on
the first rank rupee 1 and after Queen
to c2 bringing the Queen into the game
now it gets nice to e3 with an attack on
the Queen and the double attack against
the bishop here and there is no good
square for the Queen for example if you
try Queen d2 or well you can't go to
into the bottom rank if you go here then
you just get a root cap force on f1 and
after loop characters Knight will
capture you have a discovered attack on
the Queen a double attack on the Queen
at that you just have to move the Queen
here down a piece and completely busted
so some perhaps between d3 move I don't
know I'm just making moves here not to
allow the rook to infiltrate either via
rookie 2 or rook e1 still isn't all that
great because Bishop to e3 check and now
you either have to give up material or
if you move the King you're getting
checkmated Queen g5 check King h1 and
Queen to g1 is made so although it seems
like there's something to do here there
really isn't of course mama knows that
and even though he has 47 minutes on the
clock he resigned the game rightfully
and neppo takes the lead in the
tournament well not stakes he's been in
the lead since the beginning as this is
his third win in a row and interestingly
or out of those three wins tour with the
black pieces so it's gonna be a really
intense struggle if Magnus intends to
win yet another tournament this year
because he faces nipple in round seven
and Carson will have the black pieces in
that matchup and it's always interesting
between the two of them so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Tata Tomas Enrique pesos
Pinto and Eric Ehlert for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
most likely continuing the coverage of
the creation Grantchester as there are
so many well brutal games being played
here thank you all I will see you soon
have an excellent rest of your day